la posición de Alemania sobre el envío
de tanques leopardos a Ucrania enfrenta
una creciente presión no solo de sus
socios europeos sino también de su
propio gobierno el domingo por la noche
los medios preguntaron a la ministra de
asuntos exteriores si Alemania Estaba
dispuesta a permitir que Polonia enviara
sus tanques a Ucrania
Por el momento no se ha planteado la
cuestión pero si nos la plantearan no
nos interpondríamos
miembro del partido de Los verdes en la
coalición gobernante ha estado
presionando a favor de una mayor
implicación por parte de Alemania en el
conflicto sin embargo el canciller Olaf
sols sigue mostrándose escéptico
respecto a este tipo de decisiones en
militares sus evasivas a primera hora
del domingo hicieron aún más confusa la
postura de Berlín ya que reiteró que los
socios occidentales deben coordinarse
antes de enviar armas
Ucrania debe saber que no vamos a
abandonarla estaremos ayudándoles Pero
tenemos un principio y es un principio
que creo que es muy importante trabajar
juntos y consultarnos las cosas
[Música]
el ministro de defensa de Alemania se
apresuró a hacer otro comentario más
cauteloso la decisión depende de muchos
factores y se toma En la cancillería
Alemania se ha visto presionada para
tomar una decisión sobre los tanques en
leopard tras semanas de peticiones del
presidente de lenski Y es que aunque la
medida permitiría una contraofensiva de
las tropas ucranianas Olaf shorts teme
traspasar la línea Roja de Moscú y
provocar una nueva escalada de la guerra